[Musica]
già perché in carcere non si lavora fare
questa domanda a esperti economisti
ricercatori rappresentanti delle
istituzioni e oggi anche a voi
fa parte del mio lavoro
sì perché io lavoro in un carcere devo
ammettere che siccome non ho commesso
reati alla sera posso uscire e tornare a
casa lavoro in carcere da nove anni qui
a torino
all'istituto lorusso e cutugno che per
gli amici e il carcere delle vallette
dove coordino le attività di una
cooperativa sociale in una sezione
maschile e presso la sezione femminile
oggi proverò a raccontarvi qual è la mia
idea di carcere
il carcere è visto spesso come un luogo
buio fastidioso di cui non ci vogliamo
occupare è un po come certe vecchie
brutte cantine di casa nostra dove
mettiamo quello che vogliamo nascondere
che non ci interessa più quello che è
rotto o corrotto e il verbo marcire è
spesso associato al carcere dovrebbe
marcire in galera si urla magari anche a
ragione
peccato che a far marcire le persone in
carcere si fa più dispetto alla società
civile che a quella incivile e perché
tenere una persona per lungo tempo in
carcere senza fare nulla
significa che probabilmente uscirà
peggiore di come ci è entrato oggi in
italia ci sono quasi 55 mila detenuti
di questi il 34 per cento e in attesa di
una sentenza di condanna definitiva è un
sistema che costa il nostro paese
3 miliardi di euro all'anno
significa 140 euro al giorno per ciascun
detenuto
e poi c'è questo dato quello della
recidiva la percentuale di chi ricade di
chi torna in carcere dopo aver già
commesso altri reati
non ci sono statistiche ufficiali perché
è un dato complesso da calcolare ma vari
di affidabili studi empirici ci dicono
che la percentuale oscilla tra il 60 e
il 75 per cento è troppo è troppo perché
capite che il carcere rischia di
diventare e diventa un sistema di porte
girevoli un continuo entrare uscire
entrare uscire che ha costi sociali ed
economici troppo elevati
di certo la sicurezza dei cittadini non
migliora e si finisce per alimentare una
fabbrica di manodopera a disposizione di
un'economia illegale della criminalità
comune o peggio ancora della criminalità
organizzata
proverò a dimostrarvi che è possibile
immaginare un idea di carcere diverso
d'altra parte anche le cantine quelli di
cui parlavo prima
possono cambiare nel tempo sul catalogo
di una nota azienda svedese
ce ne sono di molto belle sembrano quasi
appartamenti e capita che qualcuno
guardi meglio nella propria cantina e
possa scovare un rembrandt o un mobile
di grande valore
a volte basta guardare le cose con un
occhio diverso
la stessa cosa dovremmo cominciare a
fare con il carcere
guardarlo come un luogo di opportunità
per chi lo abita e di minor peso per
tutti noi portare lavoro in carcere è
una grande e difficile sfida ma se la
raccogliamo può portare più sicurezza
per i cittadini più risorse umane a
disposizione di una società sana più
economia legale meno sprechi oggi nelle
carceri italiane
i detenuti che lavorano per imprese
cooperative sociali sono meno di 2500
e il 4,5 per cento di tutta la
popolazione detenuta per queste persone
da recidiva di cui parlavamo prima si
abbatte in maniera clamorosa
scende sotto il 20 per cento
e se al lavoro associamo le misure
alternative al carcere
questa percentuale si abbassa
ulteriormente le misure alternative al
carcere come la detenzione domiciliare
la semilibertà che consente alle persone
di uscire dal carcere mattino andare a
lavorare e farvi ritorno alla sera
l'affidamento in prova significa
rispettare certe prescrizione non
frequentare pregiudicati certi locali
rientrare entro una certa ora e svolgere
attività di positive di utilità e di
mediazione sociale financo risarcire le
vittime le vittime di cui troppo spesso
ci dimentichiamo le imprese e le
cooperative che lavorano nelle carceri
si trovano in tutta italia da aosta a
palermo e cercano di sviluppare progetti
e sinergie positive con i territori
riscoprendo le tradizioni artigiane di
cui è ricco il nostro paese
valorizzandone le eccellenze
enogastronomiche in italia
l'ironia non manca mai ci
contraddistingue come popolo ed ironia
c'è anche in prigione vi racconto
qualche nome di quei prodotti di quegli
oggetti ambasciatori che raccontano di
un buon carcere a verbania c'era banda
biscotti ma invece di pianificare rapine
sfornano eccellenti biscotti di
pasticceria qui a torino c'è un pane dal
nome truffaldino farina nel sacco e vi
consiglio di assaggiarlo a venezia si
recupera il pvc con cui si fanno delle
borse le malefatte
ma detto tra noi sono fatte benissimo
e dalla sicilia arrivano dei prodotti a
base di mandorle che si chiamano dolci
evasioni e c'è anche chi si chiama
sprigioniamo sapori ma vuole soltanto
liberare torroni e crema di pistacchio
al di là dei nomi dell'ironia
quello che è importante è che le imprese
le cooperative possono offrire alle
persone che hanno svolto è seguito un
percorso meritevole una proposta seria e
continuativa equamente retribuito
professionalizzante perché in carcere si
impara un mestiere
una proposta che consente alle persone
di tracciare traiettorie migliori per il
proprio futuro per quando usciranno
dalla prigione lavorare in carcere
significa sperimentare relazioni sane
dare un senso a quel tempo ricostruire
un ponte con la società
là fuori
il lavoro in carcere può rendere quel
posto un luogo da cui si esce migliori
di come ci si è entrati portarle lavoro
in carcere un progetto ambizioso e ha
bisogno del contributo di tutti delle
cooperative che devono lavorare in
primis in maniera seria imparare a stare
sul mercato delle istituzioni che devono
accogliere i progetti più virtuosi della
società civile di tutti noi che possiamo
accogliere queste opportunità
e poi c'è bisogno di una diversa visione
del futuro
ecco provate a immaginare cosa
succederebbe se tra dieci anni in italia
lavorasse il 90 per cento della
popolazione detenuta
avremo un carcere diverso un carcere con
meno persone come le persone che hanno
commesso reati più gravi che scontano
una pena certa e così potremmo anche a
risparmiare un po di quei 3 miliardi di
euro di cui dicevo prima è avere più
sicurezza
davvero nel nostro quotidiano
coin fine quindi portare lavoro in
carcere una grande idea è un'idea
vincente
è un'idea rivoluzionaria però vi devo
confessare che non l'abbiamo inventata
noi l'abbiamo copiata e sapete da chi
dalla costituzione della repubblica
italiana articolo 27 comma 3 le pene non
possono consistere in trattamenti
contrari al senso di umanità e devono
tendere alla rieducazione del condannato
grazie
[Applauso]